Continental Tire Coach's Corner brings
us stock rivers the Clippers head coach
join us here in the man cave looking
good man looking good like you know uh
where would you rank among your players
as far as shooting among the players man
yeah probably in the middle of shooting
the middle in the row free-throw
shooting up high because I became a
pretty good free-throw shooter but
shooting I was in the average shooter
yeah but but who's the shooter that
you've seen where you just go that that
is unbelie-- instead Curry and klay
Thompson yeah but is there somebody
where you go that that's just not fair
well those two assistants I'm coming off
a Golden State game where you know it's
funny klay Thompson when he gets warm
yeah he's a great shooter all the time
and then he goes like in those video
games where you can push a button and go
to them where you catch on fire yeah
like literally oh that's that's clay you
know to me but I would say just those
those two guys curry and Thompson now
you know Ray Allen can you tell when
somebody's getting warm as the opposing
coach where you go like you just sense
that klay Thompson is yeah you can sense
it you can see it coming sometimes you
know a couple of years ago Paul George
of all guys you know he's a great
shooter anyway but he had a game when it
left his hand you just knew that's you
know you see those games and not a lot
you can do when when they get to those
points but when you played against
somebody do you remember
well you had the bird night he only
scored six on me nobody was guarding
bird were they well we're trying were
trying but when a guy is literally
coming up the court calling his shots
and you know bird talked a lot of trash
and that's in New Orleans that's in New
Orleans in that game we're on the free
throw line and he's like he literally
says left side three listen to him
that's that's a tough filling but okay
so you guys got Antoine Carr and cliff
Levingston got fine
by fratello I think nad Johnson for
celebrating celebrating bird yeah there
was the best film session everybody when
I see Mike we still laugh it was a
greatest film session ever because
that's back then you didn't have you
know you watched the real game and just
went you know what a video and Mike
rewound the celebration 20 times they
just kept routing that to shot he just
kept rewinding it showing the guys you
remember they're giving each other
high-fives and then somebody falls off
the bench and Lady Johnson you know
Justin falls off the bench and laughter
and Antoine Carr and cliff gives each
other high-five and our film session is
20 minutes of that it wasn't somebody
not playing good defense on the bird it
was celebrating Larry Bird tella
wouldn't let it go it just kept
rewinding I think by the bench one time
too he fell it called that one that was
the one where he fell in it he literally
said off the glass into the trainer it
was a bad night who was your trainer
O'Toole joltin greatest trainer you know
he's the greatest you know I keep with
my trainers now you could I could break
my ankle and Joey patch in the back and
say see what you can do tomorrow we play
more did you know this drama was going
on with Golden State the other night
when you had no idea I wish had it now I
really did we wouldn't have gone and
overdo it the game would have been we
won anyway but they were testing you
know Steve who complains as much as me
which no one knows sorry Steve but
that's true
he was complaining our game Durant
it was a it was a testy game that's in
our team if you've seen us play it's
probably going to be a testy game
because that's how we play it you have
to play yeah that's who we are and our
guys embrace that they just are who they
are and I thought the game got testy
it's funny I thought during that eight
or nine files
how coaches look at it differently I
didn't know this until that in the night
later the night I'm watching TV and the
sports and like wow I never knew this
happen
yeah they suspended you I didn't think
it was as bad either as you know
yesterday when you find on these
suspended I was surprised by that well
there were some stuff going on in Walker
yeah it has to be yeah do you guys make
a run at Jimmy Butler yeah yeah we
talked you know my guess is Tim's to
talk to everybody I did there was no
team untouched yeah in this deal but we
did talk and you know without saying
much more but you know it was a good
conversation I also was talking Elton
Brand about marquel Foltz and now it's
in his head like no it's I mean no doubt
it's really sad I hate it because he was
such a good shooter in college yeah how
do you get to this point you know I
don't know I had a like I said I had to
small dose of it one year when I broke
my wrist and I came back and I just
stopped you know I wouldn't follow
through and it became mental and you
know I was a pretty good free-throw
shooter and then I turned into a really
good one after that but the only reason
is that summer the hours that I put in
shooting free-throws which you know for
any players that's no fun yeah see we're
gonna work on your game it's boring but
you have to and I learned that lesson
myself but when it becomes mental you
know what is it in baseball no one's
ever come back to the position that they
had it in no Rick Ankiel went to the
outfield Chuck Knobloch went to the
outfield you know in basketball there's
no other position you know you can't go
to shortstop you have to play and so do
the Clippers have a sports psychologist
yeah we do we do most teams do they're
still under youth you know it's a trust
factor you know we ended up hiring a
bunch of people that the guys can choose
but there is a trust factor there
because the team hires and I still think
it's the untouched area of sport you
know golfers use it to most tennis
players are using it you know
basketball players some use it some
don't some use it when they need it
which means it's too late
you know so it's it's I worry about him
because that's that's a tough one and
you could see where he goes to the line
you just want to get it over with
oh yeah it just feels like he's not
worried about making it as much as
looking good while missing it now you're
convinced you know because again I had
like a three month period of it you
convinced that you know when you get
fouled and it doesn't go in that that's
the basketball gods they want you to
shoot two more yeah like you're praying
it goes in so it's only one free-throw I
mean you get to that point and my guess
is he's at that point Nick Anderssen
yeah remember was a great free-throw
shooter led the league at his position
in free-throw attempts misses those in
the finals the following year he was the
lowest in the league in free-throw
attempts so as Dan Quayle said the
mine's a terrible thing well also that
you guys don't want to think like you
just play you react yeah the more you
think that that's when he it makes it
worse it feels like yeah the mine is
really like thinking hurts the team you
know Pat Reilly used to say that it
really does you know you want it to be
instinctive you know and you know my
best games you know they'll ask you
after the game what did you do and
you're like I don't know you know I play
and that's what you do you practice so
much that you don't think anymore it's
instinctive
and if you're thinking on the floor it's
not a good thing he's Doc Rivers
Clippers head coach joining us tomorrow
night they played the Spurs I was also
wondering about this when you you had
that nucleus you had your big three you
had your chance
yeah why didn't why didn't it result in
a championship chemistry you know
honestly I don't know we're good enough
to be honest that's good that's the
toughest part for you to answer like as
a coach like I like to all three were
terrific
DJ Blake and CP but you know we the
first year was our chance we because
we're the last team to be cousins state
in the West which feels like Tim years
ago it does you know
and so that was our year we get up
against Oklahoma if you remember had
them beat in this series we had a tough
ending of one of the games and then we
lose the next game we're out and that
was the start but the the the three main
guys they there was chemistry issues and
so there were times where they got along
on there were times where they didn't
but I've always felt if you can't get
through that whatever it is it comes
back in times when you don't need it in
tough times when when your teams are
struggling when they're going through
pressure parts of the playoffs but the
real reason honestly we I don't think
we're good enough we were very good but
we were just not good enough but what's
your role when you sense that you don't
have good chemistry oh that's the
coach's role like for me that was a
failure I mean you wanted to figure it
out you know I remember the first year I
thought the chemistry was was not good
compared to where I just came from in
Boston with kg Paul and rape and one of
the assistant coaches who was there
before looks at me are you kidding me
this is the best has ever been and I
remember him saying that and I was like
why well then we're in trouble and you
know I never you know a lot of it was
sometimes it's just not time to win for
guys they're not ready you know they're
more concerned with everything else and
you know you have to sacrifice a lot of
your game to win the title each guy does
and at that point I don't think anybody
was ready for that but you had such big
personalities in Boston yeah kg and Paul
and then you got Rondo but they were
ready to win like that group had do you
think about it cagey Ray and Paul they'd
all done the individual stuff you know
so it was time like air mentally all the
other stuff didn't matter and kg maybe
the gradient one of the greatest leaders
ever or he'd kill you you know one of
the two but he took the team and changed
the culture himself and that was big
true did you ever hear this story that
Tim Duncan was on the elevator at the
all-star game and kg got on the elevator
and kg started like screaming in his
face with nobody around
I believe and Tim didn't react no Tim
wouldn't he but kg was like talking
trash to him and I've not heard the
story but it's believable you know being
around kg yelling you know yeah you know
what he yelled at me is if you took him
out of practice he had this thing about
practice that he should never come out
and so if you took him out it was it was
all hell that you had to deal with but
then he would mock what his guy was
doing on the floor it was so silly like
he literally if his guy jumped he would
jump if his guys slide he was slight
he'd run on the side of the floor and I
blow the whistle why would I take you
out if you're gonna do that and he yells
at me Warriors never come out of
practice so tell me if this story is
true you try to get tossed from a game
that's a true story
yeah all right tell me Stuart well it
was Danny Ainge we were in Miami and the
Masters the final Sunday masters was on
Tiger was making a run and Danny says at
halftime he's like this game that mean
anything we're already set in our
playoff position get thrown out so we
can watch the end of it so I go out and
I actually thought it was Jay Crawford
was Danny Crawford and I'm I'm going at
him like it's five seconds into the
second half and he does this he's like I
want to watch it too and so I so the
official doesn't want to throw you out
because he wants to watch it watch it -
he's punishing me which was pretty funny
have you ever been thrown out a game
that you wanted to be thrown out of
again yeah every once in a while you
know you do it for the team but does it
work no and what do you do after you
thrown out you know it's funny when you
go on the back there's nothing to do I
got thrown out one game and in Boston in
the first half
which was early to get thrown out of a
game yeah Tim downer he threw me out
five minutes into a game so I felt
powerful like when I read it but he did
I was like maybe he thought I was a
pretty good coach and and I could hurt
him but you don't do anything you sit in
the back well this game in the second
half Tibbs was actually the assister
coach he wouldn't sub and so I'm using
my cell phone trying to call the trainer
everybody's got one you're Michael
Jordan's story well my best Michael
Jordan story is I played back-to-back
games and I held him to a pretty low
number and he's walking out I was in
Atlanta you know how you had to walk by
to their home locker room to get to the
bus and he pokes his head in it just to
tell me you know great job did a great
job on me tonight you know see you next
game oh and so you know but they start
laughing like woof what tomorrow's gonna
be a tough night for you problem you
know it was it was a tough night I take
52 and I did my best work that night so
do you think that he was capable of
getting like Kobe went for 81 do you
think Mike anybody else yeah those two
would come to mind I mean Mike the thing
I loved about Mike although it's he was
so efficient you know I don't think he
gets enough credit for most of his
careers over 50% yeah you know but he
wasn't a big volume guy was no he was
just he was an efficient player you know
the North Carolina way taught him well
he's very fundamentally sound most of
the time made the right play
you know the game-winning shots by
PacSun and and Steve Kerr was because
Michael Jordan was playing with him you
know he understood that and you know he
was a dominant player maybe one of the
best defensive players to ever play the
game and had a complete killer instinct
you know but yet he was really sound I
think that's what
made them great but 81 by Kobe yeah
that's crazy
it helps that it's a competitive game
you know so you say it wasn't they 81
where you just throwing up shots to get
the number that game was close they were
down yeah and part of that game you know
but done it feel like klay Thompson the
other night the way he was shooting yeah
it's gonna get you 75
well what's amazing with clay is the
dribbles he didn't it didn't take many
dribbles and our whole game plan
you know I actually said it before the
game the more he dribbles the worse he
gets
you know when you think about yeah yeah
he doesn't dribble very often he's
actually a good dribbler he can't handle
the ball but he's such a great catch and
shoot and it's so quick that when you
make a mistake defensively you know from
a coaching standpoint right when you see
it you know it's too late you know we
have one late Tobias and Gail got mixed
up and you can see the ball in the air
and you can see where our guys were and
you knew oh boy this is not good
do you have a nickname for Jay no just
young fella it's a long name and that's
you know his actual name is longer you
know he has another word in his name he
told us that we had a little thing where
tell us them you don't know and he says
well you guys actually my name is a lot
longer than what you see you have that
Paulie
yeah Savanti yeah there it is a sheehan
gilga alexander yeah so we shortened it
to shake I'll leave you with this Seaton
does a Steve Ballmer impersonation you
Noel Michaels told me about this that's
like the coolest thing ever okay now I
don't weigh in the middle of fairway Al
Michaels
your impersonation okay now you get in
trouble if you laugh at his
impersonation of course not okay
my Balmer's got a good sense of humor
right yes okay okay all right so Seaton
saw this when the Balmer was when
Microsoft yeah right that he would come
out and you would get everybody fired
Clippers owner so see if you'll if
you'll indulge us with your Steve
Ballmer impersonation you hope to see it
a few more times it's uh it's great to
see him coming in he's Doc Rivers head
coach of the Clippers for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]